so obviously uh you guys are involved in
a number of projects every time i
almost every day on collider we're
covering something about you guys so i'm
curious do you actually know how many
things you're working on today like at
this moment as a company
oh like is there a number in our head
there is like
actually like do you actually know
everything you guys are working on
because it's a lot it is a lot i could
safely say yes that there's not like
a like a half dozen projects that we
haven't heard of yet
we have an amazing group of people that
we work with and we're um chatting all
day long and they're always keeping us
up to date and
um
the
trouble with hiring ambitious smart
people is they keep wanting to do things
and then the things they want to do keep
being really good
and they seem and they become really
competent at doing them and that's part
of why we're lucky to be able to work on
so many things
uh you guys haven't directed a feature
together a live action feature since
2014 and i think i speak for a lot of
people when i say
not acceptable so when are when are you
guys making a live action feature
together
we're uh we are working on that uh
hopefully soon we've got some stuff up
cooking and uh and hopefully
we'll we'll get to
prepping
uh
something you know this is so vague
there are scripts
there's things but there's like that
there's like a physical copy of
something on paper
that could be a movie that's in our
inboxes
do you think that you'll actually be
filming something this year uh together
or do you think it's more next year
um well i hope that we're at least
prepping something by this year uh we
you know we have a lot we have you know
we have a lot to do still on
spider-verse and
some other things uh so
we have to get a few things off our
plate before we have enough
bandwidth to uh
to start rolling picture
last question before the after party uh
very excited about clone high where are
you in the production process and when
do you think it might be
something that fans can watch
well this is the
microphone that
i use to do scudworth
so we're recording voices and
you know
it's a two season order so there's every
episode is in some
part of the process right now it makes
it a really busy time but um but it's
also really
fun so
next year or this year
that's the thing that i actually don't
know
i know that some of the episodes are in
animation right now and uh and but i
don't know when uh when it will actually
be on the air
getting into afterparty so the
information on the show says um the
eight episode first season so i wanna
know what yeah exactly is was this
envisioned as something that could go on
for multiple seasons or did you sort of
just think let's just make a cool show
and see what happens
well i mean obviously it was it was
written originally as a as a feature
film and then expanded into a series
because it seemed like
uh you could really dig in deeper to
each of the characters and give them
their own episode whereas as a as a
movie they only had a few minutes you
know each so it wasn't uh you couldn't
really
get into the complexity of of the
characters so
it was originally conceived as you know
one
complete unit but obviously
we had a lot of fun making this and you
know
right now we just are caring about
people being excited about this but
there are plenty of other
styles of storytelling uh left to
explore and uh and you know we're big
fans of the genre so anything's possible
at what point during the making of this
show did the continuity person say you
are paying me more money
she would say
we did warn them that it was going to be
uh it was going to be a real pain in the
butt because you know every episode
has
uh you know
not only different you know lighting and
uh camera work and music but each
costume costumes are different in
episode episode slightly different
and so everyone had to keep really good
track of
everything
on this production it was a real it was
a real
head
exploder
for real though um what how did you
figure out which episodes
which character's story would go in what
episode like how did you decide jasper
would be episode three
oh um this was it was
it was figured out as like a puzzle to
begin with you know like you know when i
had the idea a little over a decade ago
it was sort of how am i going to tell a
story where each
person's story advances the narrative
because part of the
issue of seeing the same scene multiple
times is each time you see that scene
you have to learn something new there
has to be a deeper understanding
of the relationship and there has to be
some sort of surprise because otherwise
it'd be really boring just to see the
same scene multiple times so
um so it was sort of figured out that
it had to go in a certain order so you
could reveal
uh the narrative and it was figured out
almost like a math problem which was why
i
named the characters with names that
started with a b c d w x y z
um
and that sort of that should tell you a
lot about chris
yeah i had to figure out how what the
order would be
uh and uh and so all became necessary
and once you start working with these
you know especially in a murder mystery
like the puzzle pieces can really only
fit together one way when you're like oh
maybe we should move
the chelsea episode earlier but it
doesn't work because everything
necessarily begets everything else
um
when when you were casting people and
were you giving how much did you tell
them about who was gonna be the actual
killer i obviously don't know who the
killer is i haven't seen episode eight
but i'm just curious because i think you
guys block shot this or you block you
know and so how early on did people know
who the killer was or were you trying to
hold that back to have everyone play it
a certain way
well it was awkward because we told
everyone they were the killer
just just to get them to take the part
so it was more of a process of telling
egypt that they weren't the killer
uh that is not actually true but we uh
we did uh everybody
once they signed on got the
got all the scripts
uh together like one giant movie because
you know writing this thing had to be a
thing that
was like making one for our movie
um so everybody once
after they came on board found out
whether they were the killer or not and
it was important because actors had to
understand what really happened and so
they could play in the early scenes
with an understanding of of everything
so they're all amazing
filmmakers and showrunners and creators
in their own right
and so
that was part of the reason why we cast
them is because they you know they could
hold all of this information in their
heads and figure out ways to play
characters
in slightly different shadings you know
eight different shadings of the same
character as a really hard thing to ask
an actor to do
um and so it was important for them to
have an understanding of the whole
sam and ben are so good together um and
i'm just curious
you know you can cast people and you can
hope for the best but when did you
realize oh [ __ ] these two are fantastic
i mean it's really early on you just
kind of go like oh this is gonna work
but they're also it's not surprising
because they're both
so well trained they're both
um have lots of time
on
um improv stages
uh sometimes together
and you just kind of
you know they just have great chops so
it's not a shock
yeah i mean what was a real special
thing about this show was that everybody
fell in love with everyone right away
everyone admired everyone and
no one was a jerk
so
everyone was happy to come to work
partially because it was shooting in the
middle of a pandemic and everyone's
excited to get out of their houses and
just see another human being so it was a
low bar but everyone was just
uh so happy to be there that you could
just feel this natural chemistry and joy
on set and i think really came through
on the show and you can really feel that
these characters
like know and like to hang out with each
other
you co-wrote episode six which is the
animated episode was that the reason why
you uh wanted to co-write that one
because of the animation
um
it really was just uh
you know what what you know my role on
this is whatever chris needs and that
was what i got
um you know that's what uh chris was
like can you tackle this we actually
i wrote it with our um now former
assistant rachel
who's um
now has a full-on writing career so part
of that was just like a
pleasure of
um
of getting to write with somebody that
we think is really talented and
um
i don't know you have to ask that's why
i was to me
i know the most about writing animation
is really tricky because it's a such a
visual
uh
medium
and
so
i knew that phil would know how to nail
it uh
the best
uh because uh you know there's a lot of
tropes that you want to avoid but it's
an opportunity for that episode is to
really see a window into zoe's
uh
internal
struggle
and visualize it in a in a way
and and i knew that
phil would know how to handle that in a
way that was uh clever and not hacky
yeah the oh i love listen i think people
are gonna be so excited that each
episode is a different genre and how
each episode is shot a different way
there's it's a very ambitious series to
pull off and you guys did such a great
job with it um not trying to put myself
into this but uh the the jasper songs
are so good um how who wrote those
things and how because they're so good
oh yeah thanks it was uh
well the writer of that episode jack
dulgin uh was one of the uh exec
producers of a crazy ex-girlfriend and
he co-wrote the songs with uh john lejoy
who we had worked with on lego movie 2
who's a very funny songwriter and
and so that was sort of both of their
influence but they turned out so great
and
ben did such a such a great job of
committing
and doing all the rehearsals for the
choreography that episode obviously was
one of the one of the harder ones to
execute there all were a challenge
in that you know as you said every
episode is its own little movie that has
its own unique production issues so
you've got the
the
action one where you gotta figure out a
car chase and a fist fight and a musical
where you kind of choreograph and write
all these songs
and animated one which has its own
entirely different pipeline so uh it
really was uh
almost seemingly impossible but that's
the type of stuff that phil and i always
like to do with stuff that seems
hard to do because and has never been
done before
yeah you guys again so good um so
recently uh zendaya and tom holland and
jacob talked about
uh
wanting to be part of spiderverse and
chris you responded on twitter by saying
call me or something along those lines
so i really need to know has phone calls
been made because jesus i want this
i don't know i know one's called me
i just got a call right now but i'd put
it straight forward to voicemail so from
zendaya it's possibly the day you know
she's all it could be
tom holland or it could be
um like a
local um political campaign asking for
money from like
uh
potential his name is potential spam i
believe his name is yes yes i love that
guy
he's such a he's so
so corny tough last name but making he
really makes a go of it
okay i can i can see the avoidance i'll
just switch to something else
so look i'm obviously over the moon that
you guys are making two spider-verse
sequels and i'm just for fans what can
you tease about the movies um and i'm
assuming that well let me what can you
tease about the movies
um well i would say that
uh
as chris pointed out we only like to do
things that are hard so
we made it really hard on ourselves
um and we've made it pretty hard on
miles too
um and uh
i don't know can you i'm looking at
chris because i'm hoping i mean
he's more circumspect than i am it is it
is a
it is a
uh as phil said a very ambitious
uh
sequel because we didn't want to just
sort of do the same thing again and so
the idea that we would be going to
different dimensions really opened up an
opportunity
artistically
to have each world have its own art
style
and
and to be able to push the folks at
image work to develop a way to have each
each dimension
feel like it was drawn by a different
artist's hand
uh and
seeing the development of that stuff is
um
is breathtaking and really the reason
that we keep doing it because it's so
hard uh to get it right
uh but it seems but the opportunity is
to like yeah push animation in
directions that
it hasn't gone yet and
uh that's what we're always trying to do
that's what chris tried to do with after
party it's what we tried to do with
mitchell's versus the machines and it's
sort of um
it's it's a problem if that's your
brand because it means you can't just go
like oh
i i do these paintings with dots and
lines i'll just do a bunch of those and
for the end of my career and and and uh
for us unfortunately we have to keep
changing it i gotta stop again
congratulations on after party so good
uh great talking with you guys
always buddy nice to see you
you